- So last month, I
introduced you to a woman
who went viral in the best
possible way, remember this?
Visitors in Telluride, Colorado
are having an amazing day
'cause it's an awesome place
just to start with that.
But they were stunned when a
bear dashed through a resort,
chased by a police officer.
The incident was caught on video,
but one woman, she's my personal hero,
was the only one to ask the
really important question.
Take a look.
(people chattering)
- Holy (beep).
Oh, my God!
- Don't tase it.
- Is that Jeff, the hot cop?
(audience laughing)
(laughing) So, what's up with Jeff?
Any chance with Jeff or? (chuckles)
- I did post a few
follow-ups on my TikTok,
sharing the news that he's married,
but even though he's off the market,
I'm still hoping to
find someone to cuff me.
(crosstalk)
(audience laughing)
- Did you say cuff me?
Oh, my God, you have got to
come in studio for an interview.
(audience applauding)
I love Grace.
Grace is back and she has an update,
so meet Nikki and meet MGK
- Hi guys, it's so great to meet you.
- Oh my gosh. Wait, I have
to get more backstory.
You're so funny. So how did
you meet Jeff the hot cop
in the first place?
- Right?
So I'm a few of my friends and
I were leaving the bars one
night and Telluride and
we were a little tipsy.
We come up on these two police officers,
both very attractive sitting
on the back of their truck.
And we went up to them.
We're kind of like messing
around with them taking photos
and yeah,
it was like just a super
random run-in it's a very small
town. So like everybody knows.
- I love Telluride.
- It's so fun. - Are you into
police officers in general?
You just like a man in uniform or...?
- So, not necessarily.
There's definitely
something attractive about
a man in uniform.
- 100%
- Yeah? Yeah. - Yes.
- But overall I'm really
just kind of looking
for someone who
has the same passion for life as I do.
I'm super like outdoorsy, adventurous.
I kind of an adrenaline junkie.
So really someone who
just matches my energy
is what I'm out here for.
- I love that. Okay.
So wait, what's your
advice to, to Grace on
you know, finding someone.
- Are you on the dating apps.
- Struck out with those
few too many times.
- Yeah. It's pretty sad on there.
- Are you a little worried on
a dating app that you're going
to run into? Like be a Dateline special.
- That's my fear.
I watch too much Criminal Minds
to be comfortable with that.
- Who are you really? That's
what I'm thinking in my head.
Are you on dating apps?
Would you do dating apps?
- I am on dating apps. - Okay.
- Yeah, I do that.
- You don't mind being a dateline special.
- So they're always like,
do you wanna go on a hike in
the woods or meeting a best buy
parking lot. Like what?
[Laughter]
I'm like, okay. I guess I'll
be the start of a podcast.
I, yeah, I don't mind it.
I just like I'm,
I'm just sad about guys like
profiles on dating apps.
I just don't think they
represent themselves well,
because men don't have as many
photos of themselves as women
do, because we have like friends
helping us out being like,
oh, you look cute.
And guys don't have that. So they.
just do like the gym.
- I have to say though,
have you seen the new
Hinge update with like the,
the voice memo thing?
- Oh, that's important.
- It's ridiculous.
- Wait, what?
- So on Hinge now you
can like record yourself,
like answering a question and
like some guys like have sung
on there. - Oh
- it's like one of the
cringiest things I've ever.
- Oh my God. I love you!
- It's the ick. You know what the ick is?
So mine's like guys in
flip-flops et cetera.
But the ick is definitely -
You like guys in flip-flops?
- No, that's my ick.
- I hate that. I'm like, we
don't ever need to see those.
- [Grace] It's not like your toes are done
- No, we never
- [Kelly] Put those away.
Okay. Wait,
I have a surprise for you
as a judge on the voice,
I am used to listening
without seeing the person.
It really does make a difference.
So I have two great guys backstage
for her to meet both just
happened to be hot cops.
(cheering)
They are legit law enforcement officers.
There is a catch.
Grace is going to have to use
her ears instead of her eyes.
And I have something to help.
Here we go. You get to sit in my chair.
So, this is what we call blind dating.
(cheering)
Okay
So when we come back,
Grace is borrowing my actual
chair from The Voice to choose
her next date. That's happening.
Alright, we are back with
Machine Gun Kelly and Nikki y'all
Also joining us is Grace who
went viral on TikTok for her
attraction to hot cops.
Today we're giving her a
chance to find love, people.
I'm letting her borrow my Voice
chair to choose between two
sexy police officers.
Instead of seeing her potential
suitors she'll have to use
her ears, which we've learned.
She loves on him.
So this should go well,
but she has to use her ears
and her heart to find love.
This is blind dating.
(cheering)
Are you ready? - Let's do it.
- You really wish you would've
known about that whole,
you know, like voice memo thing,
but let's meet your men
in blue. Here we go.
Alright!
(clapping)
I'm not going to lie. I feel
like it's someone's birthday
and we're in Vegas,
I love what's happening right
now. Y'all look so handsome.
And first of all, thank you
so much for what you do.
Thank you so much.
Okay. So go ahead and
introduce yourselves.
- First off.
- Nice to meet you.
Grace, Nikki MGK, Kelly.
I'm Matthew man. I'm a police officer.
Hollandale police department.
I've been there for almost a year.
Now when I'm not policing,
I'm a substitute teacher,
as well as a basketball
coach. I like to do.
I liked it.
(cheering)
I like to do anything where I
can interact with the youth.
Just be in the kids' lives.
'cause a lot of kids don't have
somebody that could talk to
and just try to set an
example. - [Kelly] Okay.
That's so cool.
(cheering)
Good luck. I'm just kidding
- I'm a Jonah Goddard from the
Eastridge police department.
I've been a police officer
for about three years or so.
Now one thing I love to
do as a police officer is
I love to help people. You know,
people usually call us on our
worst days and if I can just
be that light in that darkness,
that means a lot to me.
Now that being said, I
am really, really goofy.
And so I like to have a good
time. I like to have fun.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I love these guys.
Okay. Okay.
So here's how this works. Officers
Matthew and Jonah will take
turns talking just like the
voice, if Grace hears
something that she likes.
She'll hit the button.
The chair will turn and that
will be the man she chooses.
Grace can hit the button at any time,
but I strongly recommend
patience and really listening.
So, bachelors, tell us
something unique about yourself
as well as a first date idea,
Matthew, you can go first.
- Something unique about myself.
I grew up on a farm in a
small community. So you know,
the community is all really
close and I'm super family
oriented. Speaking of
family, I have 10 siblings.
(laughter)
We're all super close. I love my family.
I'm also adopted. So there's
a lot of love in my family.
And as far as the date,
I feel like my date and
I did is really unique.
I'd like to go to a trampoline
park or something and go have
fun because it brings the
inner kid out of here.
- Did you say the trampoline park? - Yes.
- I love a trampoline park. - Yes!
- That's fun, yeah.
It does start to feel like
fat camp at some point.
- But it's fun for like 20min.
- Just pay for one hour,
go to trampoline park.
It brings the inner kid out of people
so you can hear them laugh
and really see where their
heart's at.
And then I'm really big on like
just chilling in the car for
a couple hours and talking.
And let me see where your music
tastes at, where mine's at.
Cause I feel like music is
really a link to somebody's soul
So we can just get to know each other.
- [Kelly] I love it. Alright
Jonah, what about you?
- Okay. Something unique about
myself is that so I'm a very
outdoorsy person to begin
with. I love kayaking, hiking,
snowboarding. If I have
a chance to be outdoors,
I am outdoors by far. Now I am a twin.
So we grew up.
So we grew up in a very
competitive family. You know,
I gotta beat my brother.
It's just it's the law at this point,
but I grew up playing
baseball, basketball, soccer.
So I'm pretty much a dude is
going to try anything at least
at least one time.
Now, as far as the date,
let me tell you, okay.
I have to tell you this.
I love to dance.
So we're going to go dancing. Okay.
- [Kelly] I love it!
- [Jonah] We can be a concert.
- [Kelly] Nikki loves dancing as well.
- Kelly, don't!
Please stop.
- You asked me dancing
at a concert. MGK, Kelly.
In or out of uniform. I'll be there.
- [Kelly] Alright
- I feel like he's looking right at you.
- In my soul.
- So wait. So off the bat
who is in lead for you?
What do you think?
- Both the best.
- I know there's pretty good.
- I need to step my pitch.
- 10 brothers and sisters.
I'm just like, there's a
lot of people to get know.
- If you ever have a problem you got to
- If you have a flat tire,
one of them can help you
- Good point. That's a good point.
- All right, well let's
take things up a notch.
You know,
I believe in the magic of song
people and this is my voice
chair and I do make the
rules here on the show.
So I asked the officers,
Matthew and Jonah to pin
their very own love ballads.
So Grace, remember you can hit
the button when you're ready,
but listen to what they're
saying before you make your
choice is all I'm saying.
Okay. So Matthew, Jonah, and take it away.
(music plays)
- Grace, I saw your TikTok
with the bear running wild
Heard you say there's a hot
cop that you left with a smile
I don't know what you think,
when you're thinking about Jeff
But I'll show you I'll be,
the best cop that you've met
- Hello, Grace.
You were looking for Jeff,
but I want to be your cop-man.
I don't chase my would chase bears.
But for you, I would chase that bear.
So baby take my hand and give me a chance.
We can turn the little blue
lights on so we can dance.
- Grace, I'm sorry to tell
you, that this is the end
of the song that I made for you
I hope that it made you grin
I've given my all and I pray you see
that when I finish this song
this evening I'll be here
- So Grace, now here we
are on Kelly Clarkson
I flew to Cali just to
try to win your heart and
you found Jeff but I can play the part.
I want to show you that I
care first things first.
I'd still chase the bear.
(cheering)
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh!
- So come on up. First of all, Matthew,
why don't you try out for The
Voice man? What's happening?
(cheering)
What the hell just happened Matthew?
You opened your mouth.
And I was like, what?
You're like really great at singing.
- [MGK] That was weird.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
Well you sing on the
Kelly Clarkson show too.
And it was really good.
Big thanks to Matthew,
we wish you the best.
You should try out for The Voice. (laughs)
So, Grace and Jonah
are going to get to know
each other now y'all.
One more thing though, I
heard Matthew and Jonah
rehearsing before this
show and it was hilarious
and there might be a bromance brewing.
I'm just saying they were so sweet.
(cheering)
Trying to help each other out.
You can check it out at
KellyClarksonShow.com